-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award
nominated actress
you know from movies
such as "Desperado" and "Frida
and shows like "Ugly Betty
and "30 Rock."
She stars in
"The Hitman's Wife's Bodyguard,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Take the gun.
-No, I'm not doing guns
right now.
-Aah! Jesus!
-I got it.
-♪♪ Well, in the morning ♪♪
[ Gunfire ]
♪♪ Move it ♪♪
♪♪ Move it yonder ♪♪
♪♪ Move back just a little bit
[ Gunshots ]
-Oh! Ugh!
[ Breathing heavily ]
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
No, no, no, no, there's
got to be a safer way down
There's got to be
a safer way down.
There's maybe like a switch.
Okay.
[ Harmonica playing ]
Really?
-Please welcome to the sho
Salma Hayek.
How are you, Salma?
-Hi, Seth. So good to see you.
-It's so good to see you,
as well.
You're in London right now
Thank you for staying up so late
for us.
-My pleasure.
You stay late for us
every night.
-Thank you for
pointing that out.
I appreciate you
making that observation.
-[ Chuckles ]
-so, Salma, this is
a sequel to a film
"The Hitman's Bodyguard."
You did not have a giant rol
in this first film,
and now it is a sequel
that is based on --
-It was tiny, wee.
Very tiny, tiny chiquitita rol
of two days of work
in the first one.
-So, what was your reactio
when you got a call
from the director saying,
"Hey, we realized
you're the part that everybody
wants to see now"?
-Well, I was shocked.
I was shocked.
But you know what?
I thought they were
just going to make it
just a little bigger.
I didn't know they were
going to make it that big.
And I was just so pleased.
It was like divine justice
I've been waiting for
this moment all my life.
Now in my 50s,
it finally arrives,
just when I thought it was gon
and was never going to happen.
-Well, I will say,
a credit to you,
because you may be in your 50s
but you seem
incredibly well-suited for
the action scenes in this film
It was like you were ready
for this moment.
-I've been -- Yes!
I've been waiting for
this moment all my life.
All that yoga finally paid off
you know.
And also comedy. I love comedy
-You couldn't work
with two nicer gentleman
in Ryan Reynolds and
Samuel L. Jackson.
You play
Samuel L. Jackson's wife,
and I think he might be
recognized, correctly so,
as one of our finest
cursing thespians.
And yet you had to swear,
as well.
How did you feel being in
that position next to our best
-I know. I had to hold my own.
And he was very intimidating
It was very intimidating.
I was really nervous about it,
because I got to hold my own
in front of the giant.
So, I was, like,
in front of the mirror,
practicing my "mother[Bleep],"
you know?
-Yeah.
-So, I would try to see
if I could outdo him in any way.
You know, I would go like,
"Mother[Bleep]."
Mother[Bleep]!
Mother[Bleep]!"
And then, eventually, I said
"I can chill
because I get to do it
in Spanish."
-Oh, right.
-And that's where
I got very creative
because he's the king.
Nobody can measure up to him
But I do get that opportunity to
do it also in another language
-Do you have some --
Can we just hear real quick,
for those of us
who aren't bilingual,
how good it sounds in Spanish?
-Well, we don't have
the exact word.
But that's the beauty, because
then you can get more creative
We have the typically "[Bleep]."
"Oh, [Bleep], [Bleep]."
it's like a generalistic term.
It's not directed to the person.
-Right.
-But you can say "[Bleep]"
to madre,
which would mean,
"Go 'F' yourself."
But "mother[Bleep],"
it's not --
we don't have
the literal translation.
-Well, I think that shows that
you know, the Spanish people
have more respect
for the matriarchy.
-Exactly. Maybe.
-[ Laughs ]
You mentioned that you wer
sort of late to comedy.
I do want to --
Not to toot my own horn,
but you hosted "SNL"
back in the early 2000s.
I was lucky enough
to be in a sketch with you
And did you know at the time
that you would be doing a sketch
with NBC's
late-night Mount Rushmore?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, this is
the late-night team.
Oh, my God, that is so true,
and it is so well-deserved
-Thank you.
-It is so well-deserved.
Actually, what I didn't know i
that it was gonna
take that long.
-Thank you. Yeah, we kind of -
We assumed this would
sort of be our audition tape
for it.
-Yeah, it was a given.
I don't know.
I say the same thing
about my action part.
I don't know
what took them so long.
-You have a daughter
who's 13 years old.
-That's right.
-So, how --
And I know she has seen
the film, correct?
-Yeah, she insisted on this one.
She never wants to see my stuff,
but she insisted
on watching this one
and to go with her friends
And I was really
nervous and embarrassed.
I was -- I said,
"Don't bring your friends.
I'm going to
really embarrass you."
And she's like,
"You embarrass me all the time
every day, so
what's gonna be different?
And I said, "No,
but this is really raunchy
Like, really raunchy."
And she's like, "Oh, I'm sur
there's gonna be nothing
that I haven't heard or seen."
-[ Laughs ]
-Anyway, she convinced me,
and she actually --
They loved it. They loved it
And she said, "Mom,
I understand it's not you.
It's not you.
It's the character."
I was quite impressed with that.
-Yeah, I mean, she's 13.
I wouldn't be that impressed
-13 going on 18.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll be right back.
I have more to ask you.
We'll be right back
with more from Salma Hayek